Nikole Hannah Jones is an investigative reporter, these days at The New York Times. We've had her here on This American Life before too. But her first big reporting job was back in 2003. She was reporting on the schools in Durham, North Carolina. And like most places, there were good schools and there were bad schools. And at the time, it was the heyday of No Child Left Behind. Durham was working really hard to improve the bad schools.
尼科尔·汉娜·琼斯是一名调查记者，目前供职于《纽约时报》。我们之前曾在《美国生活》节目中邀请过她。但她第一份重要的报道工作是在2003年。当时她正在报道北卡罗来纳州达勒姆市的学校。和大多数地方一样，那里既有好学校也有差学校。当时正值“不让一个孩子掉队”法案的全盛时期。达勒姆市正非常努力地改善那些差学校。
And I would go to schools, and they would just always be trying these new things that actually sounded like they might work. They would do things like, "We'll put a great magnet program here. Or we are going to really focus on literacy. We're going to start an early college high school, which kids would earn college credit in high school. We're going to improve teacher quality. We're going to replace the principal. More testing."
我经常去学校，他们总是尝试各种听起来可能有效的新方法。他们会做这样的事情：“我们要在这里建立一个优秀的磁性学校项目。或者我们要真正关注读写能力。我们要创办一所早期大学高中，让孩子们在高中就能获得大学学分。我们要提高教师质量。我们要更换校长。增加考试。”
They're always talking really about the same things. I mean, you could take these conversations and go from district to district to district, and you will always hear the same things.
他们谈论的总是同样的事情。我的意思是，你可以把这些对话拿出来，从一个学区到另一个学区，你听到的永远是同样的内容。
And what she noticed was that it never worked. I mean, like, never. The bad schools never caught up to the good schools. And the bad schools were mostly black and Latino, the good schools mostly white. And sure, there might be a principal here or a charter school there who might do a good job improving student scores. But even there, they were just improving the students' scores. The minority kids in their programs were still not performing on par with white kids. They hadn't closed the achievement gap between black kids and white kids.
她注意到，这些做法从来没有奏效。我是说，从来没有。差学校永远赶不上好学校。而且差学校里大多是黑人和拉丁裔学生，好学校里则大多是白人学生。当然，可能某个地方有一位校长或一所特许学校在提高学生成绩方面做得不错。但即便在那里，他们也只是提高了学生的考试成绩。他们项目中的少数族裔孩子表现仍然赶不上白人孩子。他们并没有缩小黑人孩子和白人孩子之间的成绩差距。
And my question is, all of these different ways that we say we're going to address this issue aren't working. So what actually works? And that's what I really began to look at. And I find this one thing that really worked, that cut the achievement gap between black and white students by half.
我的问题是，我们声称用来解决这个问题的各种不同方法都没有奏效。那么，究竟什么才是有效的呢？这就是我真正开始研究的地方。我发现了这一件事，它确实有效，使黑人和白人学生之间的成绩差距减少了一半。
By half?
减少了一半？
By half. But it's the one thing that we are not really talking about, and that very few places are doing anymore.
减少了一半。但这是我们现在真正避而不谈的事情，而且几乎没有地方还在这样做。
That thing that is so effective but never discussed? That's not one of the tools that educators reach for normally? Can you guess?
那件如此有效却从不被讨论的事情是什么？那不是教育工作者通常会采取的手段吗？你能猜到吗？
Integration.
融合。
You mean just integrated schools? Just getting black kids and white kids together in the same schools?
你是说仅仅是融合学校吗？只是让黑人孩子和白人孩子在同一所学校里一起上学？
Yes.
是的。
Old fashioned, Brown versus Board of Education, 1954 technology, little kids on buses?
老派的，1954年“布朗诉教育委员会案”的技术，坐校车的小孩？
That's right. Actually, what the statistics show is that between 1971, which is where the nation really started doing massive desegregation, and 1988, which was the peak of integration in the United States, 1988 was the peak.
没错。事实上，统计数据显示，从1971年（国家真正开始大规模废除种族隔离的时候）到1988年（美国融合的巅峰时期，1988年是顶峰），情况确实如此。
School integration.
学校融合。
School integration, yes. Well, the data shows that at the start of real desegregation, the achievement gap between black and white students was about 40 points.
学校融合，是的。数据表明，在真正开始废除种族隔离之初，黑人和白人学生之间的成绩差距大约是40分。
In other words, on standardized reading tests in 1971, black 13 year olds tested 39 points worse than white kids. That dropped to just 18 points by 1988 at the height of desegregation. The improvement in math scores was close to that, though not quite as good. And these scores are not just the scores of the specific kids who got bused into white schools. That is the overall score for the entire country. That's all black children in America. Halved in just 17 years.
换句话说，在1971年的标准化阅读测试中，13岁的黑人学生比白人孩子差39分。到了1988年废除种族隔离的高峰期，这一差距缩小到了18分。数学成绩的进步幅度与之相近，虽然没有那么好。而且这些分数不仅仅是那些被送往白人学校的特定孩子的成绩。这是整个国家的总体得分。这是美国所有黑人儿童的成绩。仅仅用了17年就减半了。
When I asked Nikole if that was fast, she was all like, "Well, black people first arrived on this continent as slaves in 1619. So it was 352 years to create the problem. So yeah, another 17 to cut that school achievement gap in half? Pretty fast."
当我问尼科尔这算不算快时，她说：“好吧，黑人作为奴隶在1619年首次来到这片大陆。所以用了352年才造成这个问题。所以，再花17年时间把学校成绩差距缩小一半？相当快了。”
And so if you picture that out if we had kept going, when we had cut it by half, I don't know that we would have eliminated it totally, because there's a long history here. But you could see where we would be. We would have been so close to eliminating it.
所以，如果你想象一下，如果我们坚持下去，当我们把它减少了一半时，我不确定我们是否能完全消除它，因为这里有很长的历史。但你可以看出我们会达到什么水平。我们本可以非常接近消除它。
Nikole, why does it work?
尼科尔，为什么它有效？
I think it's important to point out that it is not that something magical happens when black kids sit in a classroom next to white kids. It's not that suddenly a switch turns on and they get intelligence or wanting the desire to learn when they're with white kids. What integration does is it gets black kids in the same facilities as white kids, and therefore it gets them access to the same things that those kids get-- quality teachers and quality instruction.
我认为必须指出的是，并不是黑人孩子坐在白人孩子旁边的教室里就会发生什么神奇的事情。并不是说当他们和白人孩子在一起时，开关突然打开，他们就获得了智慧或学习的欲望。融合所做的是，它让黑人孩子和白人孩子进入相同的设施，从而使他们获得那些孩子所能获得的相同资源——优质的教师和优质的教学。
The US Department of Education put out data in 2014 showing that black and Latino kids in segregated schools have the least qualified teachers, the least experienced teachers. They also get the worst course offerings, the least access to AP and upper level courses, the worst facilities.
美国教育部在2014年发布的数据显示，在种族隔离学校中，黑人和拉丁裔孩子拥有资历最浅、经验最少的老师。他们还获得最差的课程选择、最少的AP课程和高级课程机会，以及最差的设施。
The other thing about most segregated black schools, Nikole says, is that they have high concentrations of children who grew up in poverty. Those kids have greater educational needs. They're more stressed out. They have a bunch of disadvantages. And when you put a lot of kids like that together in one classroom, studies show, it doesn't go well.
尼科尔说，关于大多数黑人种族隔离学校，另一件事是它们集中了大量生活在贫困中的儿童。这些孩子有更大的教育需求。他们压力更大。他们有很多劣势。研究表明，当你把很多这样的孩子放在同一个教室里时，情况并不会好转。
If you're surrounded by a bunch of kids who are all behind, you stay behind. But if you're in a classroom that has some kids behind and some kids advanced, the kids who are behind tend to catch up. These kids in these classes in schools of concentrated poverty don't have that. They don't have that effect of kids who can help boost them. Everyone's behind.
如果你身边都是落后的孩子，你也会保持落后。但如果你在一个既有落后孩子又有先进孩子的教室里，落后的孩子往往会赶上来。这些在贫困集中的学校里的孩子没有那个条件。他们没有那种能帮助提升他们的孩子带来的影响。每个人都落后了。
And then they're getting the worst teacher. So it's not even like they're getting the same quality teachers as kids who are advanced. They're getting worse teachers. When you combine those two things, it is almost impossible to undo that harm. You have to break that up.
而且他们得到的还是最差的老师。所以这甚至不像他们能得到和那些先进孩子一样的高质量教师。他们得到的是更差的老师。当你把这两件事结合起来，几乎不可能逆转那种伤害。你必须打破这种局面。
This is why after years of studying this, Nikole thinks segregated schools full of poor kids are probably never going to catch up to other schools. The job is simply too hard. But integration-- before I talked to Nikole about this, I had this vague sense about integration-- maybe you had this too-- that we tried that. It didn't go so well. Which Nikole has heard before.
这就是为什么在研究多年后，尼科尔认为充满贫困儿童的隔离学校可能永远无法赶上其他学校。这项工作实在太难了。但融合——在我与尼科尔谈论这个话题之前，我对融合有一个模糊的概念——也许你也有——我们尝试过。效果并不好。尼科尔以前也听过这种说法。
Yeah, that's a pretty common thought. People say, "Well, we tried to force it and it just didn't work out." And typically what people are thinking of are places like Boston, where busing was used and where it was violent and ugly and white people just left and didn't want to deal with it.
是的，这是一种非常普遍的想法。人们会说：“好吧，我们试图强迫它，但结果并不好。”人们通常想到的是像波士顿这样的地方，那里使用了校车接送，结果暴力且丑陋，白人直接离开了，不想处理这个问题。
White people fled the school systems and basically they resegregated the school systems by fleeing.
白人逃离了学校系统，基本上他们通过逃离重新制造了学校系统的种族隔离。
Right. And I should be clear. I'm a product of busing myself. And I rode a bus two hours a day.
是的。而且我得澄清一下。我自己就是校车制度的产物。我每天坐两个小时的校车。
Where did you grow up?
你在哪里长大的？
I grew up in Waterloo, Iowa. And yes, there are black people in Iowa. I get that question all the time.
我在爱荷华州的滑铁卢长大。是的，爱荷华州有黑人。我经常被问到这个问题。
Nikole says that her parents sent her and her sister to a school across town, which was all white, except for five black kids, which included the two of them.
尼科尔说她的父母送她和她姐姐去镇另一头的一所学校，那所学校除了她们俩在内的五个黑人孩子外，全是白人。
And at the time, I didn't realize that it was a bussing or integration program. My parents told me to get on the bus and go to school, and I went where the bus took me.
当时我并没有意识到这是一个校车或融合项目。我父母告诉我上车去上学，我就去了校车带我去的任何地方。
Right.
是的。
But I didn't really understand until I started covering education that we were part of a desegregation program. And one of the things that has been challenging as I write these stories is knowing that bussing for me was actually very hard. We had to get up really early, but also we were being taken out of our community into someone else's community, where not only was it a white community but it was a wealthy community, and I was coming from a very black working class community.
但在我开始报道教育新闻之前，我并没有真正理解我们是废除种族隔离计划的一部分。在我写这些报道时，其中一个挑战是知道乘坐校车对我来说其实非常困难。我们必须起得很早，而且我们被带离了自己的社区，进入了别人的社区，那不仅是一个白人社区，还是一个富裕的社区，而我来自一个非常贫穷的黑人工人阶级社区。
And so socially, it was very difficult. You just never felt like you belonged or it was your school. I had friends and I could go to their house, but they couldn't come to mine. And there was this time when I was in middle school, there was a pool on our side of town. And then there was another pool on the other side of town. And we used to always go to the pool on the white side of town. And one day, I was like, "Hey, guys, why don't you come to my house and we can go to the pool on my side of town?"
所以在社交上，这非常困难。你从来没有觉得自己属于那里，或者那是你的学校。我有朋友，我可以去他们家，但他们不能来我家。我在初中时，我们那一侧的镇上有一个游泳池。镇的另一侧有另一个游泳池。我们过去总是去白人那边的游泳池。有一天，我说：“嘿，伙计们，为什么你们不来我家，我们可以去我那边的游泳池呢？”
And all my white friends were like, "Yeah, we're going to do it." And then that morning, one by one, they called and said they couldn't come. And to this day, that devastates me. I'll never forget how that felt. Because I knew why. I knew why they did that.
我所有的白人朋友都说：“好的，我们会去的。”然后那天早上，他们一个接一个地打电话说他们不能来了。直到今天，这依然让我深受打击。我永远不会忘记那是什么感觉。因为我知道原因。我知道他们为什么要那样做。
What did they say?
他们说了什么？
They just said, "Oh, our mom said we can't come, but you can come over here." Every last one of them. I mean, that's the thing. We somehow want this to have been easy and we gave up really fast. I mean, there was really one generation of school desegregation.
他们只是说，“哦，我妈妈说我们不能去，但你可以到这儿来。”每一个人都这样。我的意思是，这就是问题所在。我们不知何故希望这一切很容易，但我们放弃得太快了。我的意思是，实际上只有一代人的学校种族隔离废除过程。
There's a lot of data that shows that black students going through court-ordered integration, it changed their whole lives. They were less likely to be poor. They were less likely to have health problems. They lived longer. And the opposite is true for black kids who remained in segregated schools.
有很多数据表明，黑人学生通过法院强制的融合改变了他们的一生。他们变得贫困的可能性降低了。他们出现健康问题的可能性降低了。他们活得更久。而对于留在隔离学校的黑人孩子来说，情况恰恰相反。
It's so funny the way you say that-- "Well, how do we know that integration works?" You're saying well, you know from the evidence of your own life.
你那样说真有趣——“好吧，我们怎么知道融合有效呢？”你是在说，好吧，你从你自己生活的证据中知道这一点。
I know from my own life, and now being able to look at the longitudinal data on it, realizing that, yes, I am living the life that that data says you live when you have the opportunity to go to an integrated school.
我从我自己的生活中知道，现在能够查看关于它的纵向数据，我意识到，是的，我过着那些数据所说的当你有机会进入融合学校时会过上的生活。
So integration works. And yet, we do not discuss it usually as the logical way to fix schools.
所以融合是有效的。然而，我们通常不会将其讨论为修复学校的逻辑方式。
And I think I'm so obsessed with this because we have this thing that we know works, that the data shows works, that we know is best for kids. And we will not talk about it. And it's not even on the table.
我想我对这一点如此执着，因为我们有我们知道有效的东西，数据显示有效的东西，我们知道对孩子最好的东西。但我们就是不谈论它。它甚至没有被摆到桌面上来。
And so today, we thought we would put it on the table and talk about it. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, after years where very few communities were launching new desegregation programs, Nikole found a place that just three years ago, unintentionally, started school desegregation. Seriously, nobody in charge planned this. A school system got integration and Nikole got to see what happens to the kids, what happens with the parents, which is not pretty, and what happens with the politics in modern day America, when school desegregation shows up uninvited to the table by any of the usual people in charge. Stay with us.
所以今天，我们想把它摆到桌面上讨论一下。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，在经历了多年很少有社区启动新的种族隔离废除项目之后，尼科尔发现了一个地方，仅仅在三年前，无意中开始了学校融合。说真的，负责人中没人计划过这一点。一个学校系统实现了融合，尼科尔得以看到孩子们会发生什么，家长们会发生什么，这并不美好，以及当学校种族隔离在任何通常负责人意料之外出现时，在现代美国会发生什么样的政治斗争。请留下，继续收听。
And with that, I will turn things over to Nikole. A quick heads up, somebody uses a racial slur in this first part of the story.
就这样，我把接下来的时间交给尼科尔。简单提醒一下，在这段故事的开头，有人使用了种族歧视用语。
I stumbled on this place by accident. I was watching the coverage of Michael Brown almost a year ago, like the rest of America. There was one moment that I could not get out of my head. It's news footage of his mother, Leslie Mcspadden, right after he was killed.
我偶然发现了这个地方。像美国的其他人一样，我几乎在一年前就在观看关于迈克尔·布朗的报道。有一个瞬间我无法忘怀。那是他被杀后，他母亲莱斯利·麦克·斯帕登的新闻画面。
This was wrong, and that was cold-hearted.
这是错误的，这太冷酷无情了。
It was. It was! No justice, no peace!
确实。太残忍了！没有正义，就没有和平！
She's standing in a crowd of onlookers, a few feet from where her son was shot down, where he would lie face down on the concrete for four hours, dead. And this is what she says.
她站在一群围观者中，距离她儿子被枪杀的地方只有几英尺远，他在那里脸朝下躺在水泥地上四个小时，死了。这就是她所说的。
You took my son away from me. You know how hard it was for me to get him to stay in school and graduate? You know how many black men graduate? Not many!
你从我身边夺走了我的儿子。你知道我让他留在学校并毕业有多难吗？你知道有多少黑人男性毕业吗？不多！
I watched this over and over. A police officer has just killed her oldest child. It has to be the worst moment of her life, but of all the ways she could have expressed her grief and outrage, this is what was on her mind-- school, getting her son through school.
我一遍又一遍地看这个画面。一名警察刚刚杀死了她最大的孩子。这一定是她一生中最糟糕的时刻，但在她所有表达悲伤和愤怒的方式中，这就是她脑海中想的事情——学校，让她儿子完成学业。
Michael Brown became a national symbol of the police violence against black youth, but when I looked into his education, I realized he's also a symbol of something else, something much more common. Most black kids will not be shot by the police but many of them will go to a school like Michael Brown's.
迈克尔·布朗成为了警察针对黑人青年的暴力象征，但当我深入研究他的教育时，我意识到他也是另一种事物的象征，一种更常见的东西。大多数黑人孩子不会被警察枪杀，但他们中的许多人会去像迈克尔·布朗那样的学校。
It took me all of five minutes on the internet to find out that the school district he attended is almost completely black, almost completely poor, and failing badly. The district is called Normandy. It's made up of one high school, the one that Michael Brown attended, a middle school, and five elementary schools. It's in a town also called Normandy that borders on Ferguson.
我在互联网上花了五分钟就发现他所在的学区几乎全是黑人，几乎全是贫困人口，而且表现非常糟糕。这个学区叫诺曼底。它由一所高中（迈克尔·布朗就读的那所）、一所初中和五所小学组成。它在一个也叫诺曼底的镇上，紧邻弗格森。
Each year, the Missouri Department of Elementary and Secondary Education puts out a report that shows how each of its 520 school districts is doing. It's a numeric snapshot of the type of education students are receiving. Districts get points for academic achievement, for how many students graduate, for how well they're prepared for college.
每年，密苏里州中小学教育部都会发布一份报告，显示其520个学区中每个学区的表现。这是学生接受教育质量的数字快照。学区在学术成就、毕业学生人数、为大学做准备的程度等方面获得积分。
In 2014, Michael Brown's senior year, here's how the Normandy School District was performing. Points for academic achievement in English-- 0, math-- 0, social studies-- 0, science-- 0, points for college placement-- 0. It seems impossible, but in 11 of 13 measures, the district didn't earn a single point. 10 out of 140 points, that was its score. It's like how they say you get points on the SAT just for writing your name. It's like they got 10 points just for existing. Normandy is the worst district in the state of Missouri.
2014年，迈克尔·布朗高三那年，诺曼底学区的表现如下：英语学术成就积分为0，数学为0，社会研究为0，科学为0，大学安置积分为0。这似乎是不可能的，但在13项衡量指标中，该学区有11项竟然连一分都没拿到。140分里只拿到了10分，这就是它的得分。就像人们说你参加SAT考试光是写下名字就能得分一样。感觉他们拿到的这10分只是因为他们还存在着。诺曼底是密苏里州表现最差的学区。
Maybe Michael Brown's mom knew these scores. Or maybe she just knew her son's school didn't graduate about half of its black boys. I don't know. I reached out to her several times and she didn't want to talk. But in the Normandy district, mothers who are worried about the quality of the schools aren't hard to find.
也许迈克尔·布朗的妈妈知道这些分数。或者她只是知道她儿子的学校里大约有一半的黑人男孩没能毕业。我不知道。我曾几次联系她，但她不想谈。但在诺曼底学区，担心学校质量的母亲并不难找。
Over the last couple of months, I spent a lot of time with one of them, a Normandy mother named Nedra Martin. And it was through her that I learned the story of something that happened in this district, something that almost never happens anymore. Nedra grew up in Normandy and works in human resources. Her daughter, Mah'Ria, is a star student. Still, Nedra found herself worrying about Mah'Ria's education all the time.
在过去几个月里，我花了很多时间与其中一位母亲相处，她是一位名叫内德拉·马丁的诺曼底母亲。通过她，我了解到在这个学区发生的一件事，这种事现在几乎不再发生了。内德拉在诺曼底长大，在人力资源部门工作。她的女儿马丽亚是一个明星学生。尽管如此，内德拉还是发现自己一直在为马丽亚的教育担心。
Mah'Ria, to be honest with you, she wasn't having a problem. I'm just going to say, she's an awesome child, OK? I love her.
马丽亚，老实说，她没遇到什么问题。我只想说，她是一个很棒的孩子，好吗？我爱她。
When you ask them questions, Nedra, Mah'Ria, their eyes fix on each other. I've got a daughter and I kept wondering what magic parenting spell Nedra has cast to get her teenage daughter to like her so much. Nedra's older daughter went to Normandy too. She almost didn't graduate on time because the school lost track of her credits.
当你问她们问题时，内德拉和马丽亚的目光会看向彼此。我有一个女儿，我一直在想内德拉用了什么神奇的育儿魔法让她的十几岁女儿如此喜欢她。内德拉的大女儿也去了诺曼底。她差点没能按时毕业，因为学校搞丢了她的学分记录。
By the time Mah'Ria got to middle school, little things started happening that begin to worry Nedra even more. Mah'Ria usually brought home As, but when she got a C, Nedra asked the teacher why she had not been notified. The teacher told her that she had too many kids in her class to call all their parents. Nedra said teachers did not seem to care. Classes were dumbed down and often unorganized and unruly. And even things that should have been good news turned to bad news.
当马丽亚上初中时，小事情开始发生，这让内德拉更加担心。马丽亚通常带回来的都是A，但当她拿了一个C时，内德拉问老师为什么没有通知她。老师告诉她，班里的孩子太多了，没法给所有的家长打电话。内德拉说老师们似乎并不关心。课程内容被简化了，而且经常组织混乱、纪律糟糕。甚至那些本应是好消息的事情也变成了坏消息。
In seventh grade, Mah'Ria was invited to a special breakfast. It was to celebrate kids who made the honor roll. They began calling kids up, one by one, to get their certificates.
七年级时，马丽亚被邀请参加一个特别早餐会。那是为了庆祝进入荣誉榜的孩子们。他们开始一个接一个地叫名字，去领证书。
I'm like, OK, I'm next. And then another name gets called. And I had to remind myself A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H, I, J, K, L, M, N, O, P. And I'm like, my name is Pruitt-Martin. You guys skipped Pruitt.
我想，好的，下一个就是我了。然后另一个名字被叫到了。我不得不提醒自己，A、B、C、D、E、F、G、H、I、J、K、L、M、N、O、P。我心想，我的名字是普鲁特-马丁。你们跳过了普鲁特。
They never called her name. When Mah'Ria asked the school counselor about it, the counselor told Mah'Ria maybe she wasn't supposed to be there. Nedra, who had taken off of work to come, was watching from the side.
他们从来没有叫到她的名字。当马丽亚询问学校辅导员时，辅导员告诉马丽亚也许她本来就不该在那里。内德拉特意请假过来，一直在旁边看着。
She looked at me and I looked at her. Then I was like, "Something's wrong. Something is wrong." I almost started crying, really. Because I felt not embarrassed but really, really disappointed.
她看着我，我看着她。然后我说：“出事了。出什么事了。”我几乎开始哭了，真的。因为我感到的不是尴尬，而是非常、非常失望。
Mah'Ria had the invitation to the breakfast in her bag. She'd brought it just in case something like this happened. Think about that. This is a 12 year old girl who is so used to the school screwing things up that she knew enough to bring proof. It was a small thing, but for Nedra and Mah'Ria, it was the last straw.
马丽亚的包里有参加早餐会的邀请函。她带上它是为了以防万一。想想看。这是一个12岁的女孩，她非常习惯学校搞砸事情，以至于她有足够的意识带上证据。这是一件小事，但对于内德拉和马丽亚来说，这是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。
Nedra knew that the district had been performing poorly for years. In fact, it had been on probation for 15 years. Schools in Missouri get accredited by the state. Almost every district is accredited. But if you're doing really bad, you get put on notice. That's called provisional accreditation. That's supposed to be like a warning. But Normandy had provisional accreditation for 15 years. That means there are entire classes of students, nearly all of them black, who came in as kindergartners and graduated 12 years later without ever having attended a school that met state standards.
内德拉知道该学区多年来一直表现不佳。事实上，它已经被留校察看15年了。密苏里州的学校由州政府认证。几乎每个学区都获得了认证。但如果你表现得非常糟糕，你就会被发出通知。这被称为临时认证。那应该就像一个警告。但诺曼底的临时认证维持了15年。这意味着有整整几届学生，几乎全是黑人，他们从幼儿园入学，12年后毕业，却从未上过一所符合州标准的学校。
In the St. Louis area, nearly one in two black children attend schools in districts that performed so poorly the state has stripped them of full accreditation. Only 1 in 25 white children are in a district like that. That's one in two black kids, 1 in 25 white kids.
在圣路易斯地区，几乎每两个黑人儿童中就有一个就读于表现如此糟糕以至于被州政府剥夺了全面认证资格的学区。只有1/25的白人儿童身处那样的学区。那是每两个黑人孩子中有一个，而白人孩子则是25个中一个。
Nedra Decided she had to get Mah'Ria out of Normandy. She made a list of nearby school districts and private schools. Then she turned her car into a mobile situation room. The mission-- get Mah'Ria into a better school.
内德拉决定她必须把马丽亚从诺曼底接出来。她列了一个附近的学区和私立学校的名单。然后她把她的车变成了一个移动指挥中心。任务——让马丽亚进入一所更好的学校。
Obviously, when I'm at work these offices are open. When I get off, they're closed. So what I would do is take later lunches on my job, go to my car, sit in my car after I've written down telephone numbers and names the night before, and I would spend my whole lunch hour calling these offices.
显然，我在工作时这些办公室是开着的。等我下班，它们就关门了。所以我能做的就是利用工作时间的午休时间，回到车里，坐在车里，拿出前一天晚上写好的电话号码和名字，花整个午休时间给这些办公室打电话。
The nearby districts told Nedra they would enroll Mah'Ria, but since she lived outside of their boundaries Nedra would have to pay tuition, upwards of $15,000 a year. She couldn't afford that.
附近的学区告诉内德拉他们会招收马丽亚，但由于她住在他们的学区界限之外，内德拉必须支付学费，每年超过15,000美元。她负担不起。
If I would be required to pay for her get a public education then I might as well try to send her to a private school.
如果我必须为她支付公立教育的费用，那我不如试着送她去私立学校。
She checked into those, but even with financial aid, she couldn't afford private school either.
她查询了那些学校，但即使有经济援助，她也负担不起私立学校。
I was at a point of desperation. I was literally desperate to just pull my daughter out of a district that I felt failed me and my children. I was at a point of desperation. We had to do better.
我处于绝望的边缘。我真的很绝望，只想把我的女儿从一个我觉得辜负了我孩子们的学区拉出来。我处于绝望的边缘。我们必须做得更好。
In most of the thousands of poor, segregated schools in America, that would be it. Your zip code is the anchor that traps you. That would have been it for Nedra too, if it weren't for what happened next.
在美国成千上万个贫困、种族隔离的学校里，事情通常就到此为止了。你的邮政编码是困住你的锚。如果不是因为接下来发生的事情，内德拉的情况也会如此。
New tonight, a major blow to a school district in the metro area. The Missouri State Board of Education is pulling accreditation from the Normandy School District.
今晚最新消息，都会区的一个学区遭到重创。密苏里州教育委员会正在取消诺曼底学区的认证。
In January of 2013, just a few months after that breakfast, Normandy lost its accreditation from the state. No one really explained why they'd lost it after all this time. Remember, they'd been on probation for 15 years. The school stayed open, but this rare event triggered a little known Missouri law called the transfer law. The transfer law gives students in unaccredited districts the right to transfer to a nearby accredited one for free. Any student in Normandy was now allowed out.
2013年1月，也就是那次早餐会几个月后，诺曼底失去了州政府的认证。没有人真正解释为什么在这么长时间后他们失去了认证。记住，他们已经被留校察看15年了。学校保持开放，但这个罕见的事件引发了一项鲜为人知的密苏里州法律，即转学法。转学法给予无认证学区的学生免费转入附近有认证学区的权利。现在任何诺曼底的学生都可以离开。
I was elated. I was just so excited, like God had of truly answered my prayers. Because that sense of desperation, it was a burden. It was honestly a weight lifted off my shoulders.
我感到非常振奋。我太兴奋了，仿佛上帝真的回应了我的祈祷。因为那种绝望感是一种负担。老实说，那是我肩上卸下的重担。
She told me and I was like, "What? What does that mean?" And she was like, "That means you get to go to a different school district." I was like, "What? Say that again? Really?" I so happy.
她告诉我时，我问：“什么？那意味着什么？”她说：“那意味着你可以去不同的学区。”我说：“什么？再说一遍？真的吗？”我太高兴了。
I was just excited. I think Mah'Ria and I got together and just did a swing dance of some kind.
我只是很兴奋。我想马丽亚和我聚在一起跳了一种摇摆舞。
Do you remember that conversation at home?
你还记得家里的那次谈话吗？
We were so happy.
我们当时太高兴了。
Under the law, while Normandy students can enroll in any nearby accredited district, Normandy has to provide transportation to just one. Normandy officials chose a district called Francis Howell. Francis Howell was 85% white. It sits across a river in another county, roughly 30 miles away from Normandy. One of the best districts in Missouri was just five miles away.
根据法律，虽然诺曼底学生可以进入附近的任何有认证学区，但诺曼底必须负责提供前往其中一个学校的交通。诺曼底官员选择了一个名为弗朗西斯·豪威尔的学区。弗朗西斯·豪威尔85%是白人。它位于河对岸的另一个县，距离诺曼底大约30英里。密苏里州最好的学区之一其实就在5英里外。
It would have been very easy for Normandy students to get there. Why not send them there? Well, if you don't want students to leave your district, one way to keep them is to make leaving inconvenient. Make them ride a long distance to school every day. Though Normandy officials deny that's why they chose Francis Howell.
诺曼底的学生要到那里去本来非常容易。为什么不送他们到那儿呢？好吧，如果你不想让学生离开你的学区，保持学生的一种方法就是让离开变得不便。让他们每天坐很远距离的车去上学。尽管诺曼底官员否认这就是他们选择弗朗西斯·豪威尔的原因。
Douglas Carr was a teacher in the Normandy district. He says when they first heard about the transfer option on the news, a lot of the Normandy teachers didn't expect many kids would take it.
道格拉斯·卡尔曾是诺曼底学区的一名教师。他说当他们在新闻中第一次听到转学选项时，很多诺曼底老师没想到会有多少孩子会选择它。
Well, honestly, I thought, "Well, how many parents are going to want to get their kids up early and send them to a school 30 miles down the highway?" That, to me, was a little extreme.
说实话，我想，“好吧，有多少父母愿意让孩子起得很早，把他们送到30英里外的高速公路尽头的学校去？”对我来说，那有点极端。
1,000. That's how many kids wanted to do that. That fall, fully one quarter of Normandy students chose the evacuation plan the law created, even though many of them would have to get on a bus at 5:00 in the morning and travel a good 30 miles away.
1000个。这就是有多少孩子想这样做。那个秋天，足足四分之一的诺曼底学生选择了法律创造的撤离计划，尽管他们中的许多人必须在凌晨5点上车，旅行整整30英里。
The word "integration" does not appear in Missouri's transfer law. When the law was passed, no one thought an entire district would lose accreditation. Integration was not the law's intent. But the Normandy kids are almost all black, the Francis Howell kids nearly all white. And that is how Missouri accidentally launched a school integration plan in what was an unfashionably late year for such a thing-- 2013.
“融合”这个词并没有出现在密苏里州的转学法中。当法律通过时，没人想到整个学区会失去认证。融合并非法律的意图。但诺曼底的孩子几乎全是黑人，弗朗西斯·豪威尔的孩子几乎全是白人。而这就是密苏里州如何意外地在这样一个过时的年份——2013年，发起了一个学校融合计划。
Though Normandy chose to provide free transportation to the Francis Howell school district, Francis Howell wasn't part of that decision. By law, they had no say in the matter. So a week after the announcement that Normandy would bus kids to Francis Howell, officials there held a town meeting to talk about it. Nedra and Mah'Ria decided to go.
虽然诺曼底选择提供前往弗朗西斯·豪威尔学区的免费交通，但弗朗西斯·豪威尔并没有参与这个决定。根据法律，他们对此事没有发言权。因此，在宣布诺曼底将用校车把孩子送到弗朗西斯·豪威尔的消息一周后，当地官员召开了一次市政会议来讨论这件事。内德拉和马丽亚决定去参加。
That night, it was a traffic jam getting there. I mean, because it was packed. To get up in this town hall meeting, you would think it was a celebrity in town or something. That's how crowded it was.
那天晚上，去那里的路上交通堵塞。我的意思是，因为那里挤满了人。在市政厅会议上站起来发言，你会以为城里来了什么名人或者什么的。就是那么拥挤。
They parked and walked in. Mah'Ria looked around, surveying the gym-- a sea of 3,000 mostly white faces.
他们停车后走了进去。马丽亚环顾四周，审视着体育馆——一片3000张大多是白色的面孔。
Bleachers on each side, those were filled. Then you had chairs that were in two columns, and people were filling up those seats to say something in the mic.
两边的看台都坐满了人。然后你有两排椅子，人们填满了那些座位，想在麦克风前说些什么。
Hello, my name is Rebecca and I have children in the district. And I'm concerned.
大家好，我的名字是丽贝卡，我在该学区有孩子。我很担心。
St. Louis Public Radio recorded the meeting. One by one, parents tick off concerns. There are questions about class sizes, money, how this will affect special ed, fire safety.
圣路易斯公共广播电台录下了会议。家长们一个接一个地列举担忧。有关于班级规模、资金、这将如何影响特殊教育、消防安全的问题。
Once Normandy comes in here, will that lower our accreditation?
一旦诺曼底进来了，那会降低我们的认证吗？
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
A woman says she was an education professor and warned Francis Howell officials not to be naive about the type of students they'd be receiving.
一位女士说她是教育学教授，警告弗朗西斯·豪威尔官员不要对他们即将接收的学生类型天真。
So I'm hoping that their discipline records come with them, like their health records come with them.
所以我希望他们的纪律记录能随他们一起带过来，就像他们的健康记录一样。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
The elected school board was sitting at tables in the front of the gym. Now and then, one of them jumped in.
当选的校董会成员坐在体育馆前面的桌子旁。偶尔，其中一人插话。
I just want to remind everybody that this timeline, nor this solution, are solutions that Francis Howell would have chosen either. We're doing the best that we can. It hasn't even been two weeks ago that we've been notified. We did find out yesterday that those student scores will become our scores.
我只是想提醒大家，这个时间表，也不是这个解决方案，都不是弗朗西斯·豪威尔会选择的方案。我们正在尽我们所能做到最好。我们收到通知甚至还不到两周。我们昨天确实发现那些学生的成绩将成为我们的成绩。
[GROANING]
[呻吟声]
One mother asked why residents did not get to vote on letting in Normandy kids like they vote on public transportation.
一位母亲问为什么居民不能像投票决定公共交通那样投票决定是否让诺曼底的孩子进入。
Years ago, when the MetroLink was being very popular, St. Charles County put to a vote whether or not we wanted the MetroLink to come across into our community. And we said no. And the reason we said no is because we don't want the different areas [INAUDIBLE] coming across on our side of the bridge, bringing with it everything that we're fighting today against.
几年前，当MetroLink非常受欢迎时，圣查尔斯县进行了一次投票，决定我们是否希望MetroLink穿过大桥来到我们的社区。我们说不。而我们说不的原因是因为我们不想让不同的区域（听不清）来到我们桥的这一边，带来我们今天正在对抗的一切。
A mother named Beth Cirami approaches the microphone.
一位名叫贝丝·西拉米的母亲走向麦克风。
This is what I want to know from you. In one month, I send my three small children to you, and I want to know is there going to be metal detectors?
这就是我想从你们那里知道的。一个月后，我把我的三个小孩送到你们那里，我想知道是否会有金属探测器？
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Because I want to be clear. I'm no expert. I'm not you guys. I don't have an accreditation. But I've read. I've read, and I've read, and I've read. So we're not talking about the Normandy School District losing their accreditation because of their buildings, or their structures, or their teachers. We are talking about violent behavior that is coming in with my first-grader, my third-grader, and my middle schooler that I'm very worried about. And I want to know. You have no choice, like me. I want to know where the metal detectors are going to be, and I want to know whether your drug sniffing dogs are going to be. And I want-- this is what I want. I want the same security that Normandy gets when they walk through their school doors, and I want it here.
因为我想说清楚。我不是专家。我不是你们这些家伙。我没有认证。但我读过。我读了，又读了，又读了。所以我们谈论的不是诺曼底学区因为他们的建筑、结构或老师而失去认证。我们谈论的是暴力行为，随着我的三年级、一年级和初中生进来了，我非常担心。我想知道。你们没有选择，像我一样。我想知道金属探测器会放在哪里，我想知道你们的缉毒犬会在哪里。而且我想要——这就是我想要的。我想在诺曼底的孩子走进他们的校门时得到同样的安保，我也想在这里得到。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
And I want that security before my children walk into Francis Howell. Because I shopped for a school district. I deserve to not have to worry about my children getting stabbed, or taking a drug, or getting robbed. Because that's the issue. I don't care about the taxes.
而且我想在我的孩子们走进弗朗西斯·豪威尔之前就得到那种安保。因为我挑选了学区。我值得不用担心我的孩子被刺伤、服药或被抢劫。因为那才是问题所在。我不在乎税收。
To be clear, Normandy did not lose its accreditation because of violence. It's easy to judge these parents, but I think part of what makes this scene so startling is that we rarely fight these battles anymore. The reaction to large numbers of black children moving into white schools would probably sound no different in New York, or Chicago, or Boston. It's just that, in most of the country, no one is even trying. These parents don't want to try either. So one of them offered a helpful solution.
澄清一下，诺曼底失去认证并不是因为暴力。评判这些家长很容易，但我认为让这一幕如此令人震惊的部分原因是，我们几乎不再进行这些战斗了。大量黑人儿童进入白人学校的反应，在纽约、芝加哥或波士顿听起来可能没什么不同。只是，在全国大部分地区，甚至没人尝试过。这些家长也不想尝试。所以其中一个提供了一个有用的解决方案。
Yeah, you're absolutely right. We have to do this. We have to follow the laws. We don't have to like it, and we don't have to make it easy. Has anyone considered changing our school start times? Moving start times up 20 minutes, maybe 40 minutes? Making it a little less appealing?
是的，你完全正确。我们必须这样做。我们必须遵守法律。我们不必喜欢它，也不必让它变得容易。有人考虑过更改我们的上学时间吗？把上学时间提前20分钟，也许40分钟？让它稍微不那么吸引人？
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
I knew that there would be negative opinions but not that negative. I didn't think it would be like that.
我知道会有负面意见，但没想到会那么负面。我没想到会那样。
Mah'Ria was watching it all on the monitors in an overflow room. At a certain point, she grabbed her mom's hand and told her she wanted to speak at the mic.
马丽亚在溢出室的显示器上看着这一切。在某个时刻，她抓住了她妈妈的手，告诉她她想在麦克风前发言。
Because I felt that I needed to represent what if your kid was in a Normandy high school and they were just offered this opportunity, and other parents are saying "We don't want you here." How are you going to feel? Your kid's going to cry because parents are saying how awful your kid is, when really they're being put in a box because they're not like that. We're just stuck there because we're not open to the opportunities. And now we're open to them, and now you want to be all mean, talking about how you're afraid of how big the class is going to be, the violence in the schools. And so-- [SIGHS]
因为我觉得我需要代表一下，如果你的孩子在诺曼底高中，他们刚刚得到这个机会，而其他家长在说“我们不欢迎你来这儿”。你感觉会怎样？你的孩子会哭，因为家长们在说你的孩子有多糟糕，而实际上他们被贴上了标签，因为他们不是那样的人。我们只是被困在那儿，因为我们没有获得机会。而现在我们获得了机会，而现在你们想变得刻薄，谈论你们害怕班级会有多大，学校里的暴力。所以——[叹气]
That's what she planned to say.
这就是她计划说的。
So I had to walk out, go to the big gym. And we were standing by the door, me and my mom were walking towards the [INAUDIBLE] and I had hesitated. I didn't even get halfway to the microphone because of what the parents were saying. I stopped the second to last row of chairs, because I did not want to say anything anymore.
所以我不得不走出去，去大体育馆。我和妈妈正走到门口，正走向（听不清），我犹豫了。我甚至没有走到麦克风的一半路程，因为家长们在说的话。我在倒数第二排椅子停了下来，因为我不想再说什么了。
And then this lady, I don't remember who she was. She was like, "I'll hold your hand." Because I started getting a little teary eyed. But I just couldn't do it.
然后那位女士，我不记得她是谁了。她说：“我会握住你的手。”因为我开始有点热泪盈眶了。但我就是做不到。
Nedra saw her daughter freeze. She said she thought about Ruby Bridges, the first black child to attend an all white elementary school in the South. She's the little girl guarded by US marshals in the famous Norman Rockwell painting called The Problem We All Live With.
内德拉看到她的女儿僵住了。她说她想到了鲁比·布里奇斯，第一个在南方进入全白人小学的黑人孩子。她是那幅著名的诺曼·洛克威尔画作《我们共同居住的问题》中被美国法警护送的小女孩。
We're still dealing with that today. We're still dealing with that today. I kept telling myself, as if I was talking to those parents who were not embracing this decision, my child may be the doctor that saves your life one day. My child may be the lawyer that defends your child one day. How dare you.
我们今天仍在处理这个问题。我们今天仍在处理这个问题。我一直对自己说，就好像我是在对那些不接受这个决定的家长说话，我的孩子有一天可能会是救你命的医生。我的孩子有一天可能会是为你孩子辩护的律师。你们怎么敢。
The conversation in the gym is taking place in one of the most segregated metropolitan areas in the country. Of course, there are poor white children in the St. Louis area, but they live in mostly middle class areas, so they aren't attending schools as terrible as Normandy's. In St. Louis, poor white children are twice as likely to go to good schools than black children of all incomes. But race barely comes up that night, except when white parents insist it is not the issue.
体育馆里的谈话发生在全国种族隔离最严重的都会区之一。当然，圣路易斯地区有贫困的白人儿童，但他们生活在大多是中产阶级的地区，所以他们不会上像诺曼底那么糟糕的学校。在圣路易斯，贫困白人儿童进入好学校的可能性是各类收入黑人儿童的两倍。但那天晚上种族问题几乎没被提及，除非白人家长坚持这不是种族问题。
We have both-- my husband and I both have worked and lived in underprivileged areas in our jobs. This is not a race issue. And I just want to say to-- if she's even still here-- the first woman who came up here and cried that it was a race issue, I'm sorry, that's her prejudice calling me a racist because my skin is white and I'm concerned about my children's education and safety.
我们——我丈夫和我——都在我们的工作中在贫困地区工作和生活过。这不是种族问题。我只想对——如果她还在的话——第一个上来哭诉这是种族问题的那位女士说，对不起，那是她的偏见，因为我的皮肤是白色的，我关心我孩子的教育和安全，她就称我是种族主义者。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
This is not a race issue. This is a commitment to education issue.
这不是种族问题。这是一个对教育承诺的问题。
The year the Supreme Court handed down the Brown versus Board of Education ruling banning school segregation, St. Louis was the second largest segregated school district in the country. It was 1954. After a lot of resistance, many school districts went through desegregation battles, but St. Louis came to it extraordinarily late.
最高法院发布禁止学校种族隔离的“布朗诉教育委员会案”裁决的那一年，圣路易斯是全国第二大实行种族隔离的学区。那是1954年。在经历了很多抵制后，许多学区经历了种族隔离的废除斗争，但圣路易斯在这方面表现得异常迟缓。
Real desegregation didn't get going in St. Louis until the 1980s. Even then, it was only because black families sued. But by that point, there were hardly any white kids left to integrate with. That's why a federal judge ordered white suburban schools to take thousands of black students from the city to the suburbs. He did that because he said St. Louis's white suburbs shared the blame for the segregation in the city schools.
圣路易斯的真正废除种族隔离直到20世纪80年代才开始。即便如此，也只是因为黑人家庭起诉了。但到了那时，几乎没有白人孩子留下来进行融合了。这就是为什么联邦法官命令白人郊区学校接收来自市区的数千名黑人学生。他这样做是因为他说圣路易斯的白人郊区对城市学校的种族隔离负有共同责任。
This was 30 years, a full generation after Brown. And the students who went through that, some of them, anyway, grew up to be the parents in the Francis Howell gym. So when they got to the mic, they aren't just talking about the current situation. A lot of what they're saying is a referendum on what happened to them when they were kids. For instance, here's how Beth Cirami, the mother of three who was asking for metal detectors, began her remarks.
这是布朗案之后30年，整整一代人之后。而经历过这一切的学生，至少其中一些，长大后成了弗朗西斯·豪威尔体育馆里的家长。所以当他们走到麦克风前时，他们讨论的不仅仅是当前的情况。他们所说的大部分内容是对他们小时候经历的一种公投。例如，这是三个孩子的母亲贝丝·西拉米（她曾要求安装金属探测器）开始她的发言的方式。
Being from Jennings, I've watched the dismantling of an award-winning school district. I've watched it. I went to Catholic school because I had to. Not because I wanted to, but because I had to. So I know the routine.
作为詹宁斯人，我目睹了一个屡获殊荣的学区的拆解。我亲眼目睹了。我去上了天主教学校，因为我不得不去。不是因为我想去，而是因为我必须去。所以我知道这套程序。
This is how white parents in the gym frame the story, that schools failed in the past because black children were forced in. That's what went wrong, not the other part of the equation, that white families chose to leave. But the few black parents who stand up to speak have a remarkably different memory of the exact same period of time.
这就是体育馆里的白人家长勾勒出的故事，他们认为过去学校失败是因为黑人孩子被强行塞了进来。那就是出了错的地方，而不是等式的另一部分，即白人家庭选择了离开。但少数站起来发言的黑人家长对同一时期有着非常不同的记忆。
I'm a native of St. Louisan, was part of the deseg program. Very great opportunity for me. I was a great student. Worked out for me. And my question is that, what are we doing as far as helping with the transition of these students coming into Normandy?
我是圣路易斯本地人，曾经是种族隔离废除计划的一部分。对我来说是非常好的机会。我是个好学生。对我来说结果很好。我的问题是，在帮助这些进入诺曼底的学生过渡方面，我们做了什么？
A generation of black St. Louis residents, tens of thousands of them, remember the St. Louis desegregation program just as she does, as a great opportunity. They will be the first to tell you it was hard, but also that it was necessary. And for the most part, it worked. In the schools where white families chose to stay, test scores for black transfer students rose. They were more likely to graduate and to go to college. After years of resistance, St. Louis had created the largest and most successful metro-wide desegregation program in the country.
一代圣路易斯的黑人居民，成千上万的他们，像她一样记得圣路易斯的废除种族隔离计划，将其视为一个伟大的机会。他们会首先告诉你那很难，但也很有必要。而且在很大程度上，它起作用了。在白人家庭选择留下的学校里，黑人转校生的考试成绩上升了。他们更有可能毕业并进入大学。在经历了多年的抵制后，圣路易斯建立起了全国规模最大、最成功的都会区废除种族隔离计划。
But from the moment it started, state officials worked to kill it. In 1999, just 16 years after real desegregation came to St. Louis, the desegregation order ended. Just a much smaller voluntary desegregation program remains. Michael Brown's mother, by the way, was part of that brief 16 year window. She was one of the students who was bussed out of St. Louis when she was a kid. But her own son, Michael, went to one of the most segregated districts in the state.
但从一开始，州政府官员就致力于摧毁它。1999年，在真正的种族隔离废除来到圣路易斯仅仅16年后，这项命令结束了。只留下了一个规模小得多的自愿种族隔离废除计划。顺便提一下，迈克尔·布朗的母亲就是那短暂的16年窗口期的一部分。她是小时候被送出圣路易斯的学生之一。但她自己的儿子迈克尔，却上了一所全州种族隔离最严重的学区。
This is what happened in cities all over. With Brown versus Board of Education, we as a nation decided that segregated schooling violated the constitutional rights of black children. We promised that we would fix this wrong. And when it proved difficult, as we knew it would be, we said integration failed instead of the truth, which is that it was working but we decided it wasn't worth the trouble.
这就是在所有城市发生的事情。通过布朗诉教育委员会案，我们作为一个国家决定，种族隔离的学校教育违反了黑人儿童的宪法权利。我们承诺将修复这个错误。当它被证明很困难时，正如我们所知道的那样，我们说融合失败了，而不是说出真相，即它实际上正在起作用，但我们认为它不值得费这个劲。
I don't care about everything else that falls by the wayside, because it will, two to three years when we all move out of the district. I care about--
我不在乎其他任何被抛弃的事情，因为当我们在两三年内搬离这个学区时，它会发生的。我关心的是——
It's not an empty threat. "If you let those children in, we will leave-- again."
这不是一个空洞的威胁。“如果你们让那些孩子进来，我们将再次搬走。”
And let me assure you. I personally know a family in the Fox School District that was shopping for houses in our school district. They were negotiating on a home. And when this came on the news, they ended negotiations. So--
让我向你们保证。我个人认识福克斯学区的一个家庭，他们曾经在我们的学区买房。他们正在商谈一套房子。当这件事出现在新闻上时，他们中止了谈判。所以——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
On the ride home, Mah'Ria felt intimidated, but she was determined to go to Francis Howell.
在回家的路上，马丽亚感到被恐吓了，但她决心要去弗朗西斯·豪威尔。
I actually kept telling myself, "The parents aren't the one that's going to the schools. It's the kids. Keep reminding yourself that."
我实际上一直对自己说，“去上学的不是家长，而是孩子。一直提醒自己这一点。”
And so, though she didn't think about it this way, that fall, Mah'Ria joined an old American tradition-- black children headed on buses to heavily white schools that had been forced by the courts to take them.
所以，尽管她没有以这种方式思考，那个秋天，马丽亚加入了一个古老的美国传统——黑人儿童坐上校车前往那些被法院强制接收他们的白人学校。
She hadn't ridden the school bus since she was little. On the first day of school, she rose to catch the bus at 5:45 AM. She found a seat, rode the 30 miles to Francis Howell, and as the bus pulled into the school parking lot, she peered nervously through the window. And what she saw surprised her.
她小时候就没坐过校车。开学第一天，她在凌晨5点45分起床赶校车。她找到了一个座位，坐了30英里来到弗朗西斯·豪威尔，当校车驶进学校停车场时，她紧张地透过窗户看去。她所看到的让她吃惊。
It was great. Because when I got there, they had their little cheerleading squad cheering for us when we walked through the door-- "Welcome to Francis Howell," cheers like that. I'm not a cheerleader, so I don't know exactly what they were saying, but just cheering, doing high kicks and everything like that. It was great. I loved it.
这太棒了。因为当我到达那里时，他们有拉拉队在欢迎我们，当我们走进门时在欢呼——“欢迎来到弗朗西斯·豪威尔”，那样的欢呼。我不是拉拉队员，所以我不知道他们具体在说什么，但只是欢呼、高踢腿之类的。这太棒了。我很喜欢。
Francis Howell administrators would not talk to me, but best as I can tell, some teachers at the school were horrified by what happened at the parents meeting. And they wanted to make sure the new students felt welcomed. Here's Nedra.
弗朗西斯·豪威尔的管理人员不愿与我交谈，但据我所知，学校里的一些老师对家长会上发生的事情感到震惊。他们想确保新学生感到受欢迎。这是内德拉说的。
I mean, they celebrated that the transfer students were there.
我的意思是，他们庆祝转校生的到来。
Were you there?
你在那里吗？
I was there.
我在那里。
So you followed the bus?
所以你跟着校车走？
I did, I did, I did.
我跟着，我跟着，我跟着。
Can I just say that during desegregation, this is what parents did? They put their kids on the bus to go integrate the schools, and they followed behind because they needed to make sure their kids were OK.
我能说在种族隔离废除期间，家长们就是这样做的吗？他们把孩子送上校车去融合学校，然后跟在后面，因为他们需要确保孩子没问题。
Yeah. Just see how she was on the bus. You know?
是的。只是看看她在校车上怎么样。你知道吗？
Just make sure she was OK.
只是确保她没事。
Yeah, yes.
是的，没错。
You must have just exhaled.
你一定松了一口气。
Exhaled. I told myself, "OK, it's all good. She is going to be OK."
松了一口气。我对自己说，“好吧，一切都好。她会没事的。”
That day, Mah'Ria was just the new kid in a new school, trying to make her way through her first few classes.
那天，马丽亚只是新学校里的新生，试图度过她的前几门课程。
The first person that I met at Francis Howell was Brittany. I love her. I didn't expect to make a friend that fast, because I remember I think it was after my third or fourth hour, I had went to lunch. I didn't know where to sit or anything like that. So I sat at a table where a couple of girls were, and I just sat there. And then she came over and she's like, "Hi, my name is Brittany." And I was like, "Hi, I'm Mah'Ria." And she just really got to know me.
我在弗朗西斯·豪威尔见到的第一个人是布列塔尼。我爱她。我没想到会这么快交到朋友，因为我记得那好像是第三或第四节课之后，我去了餐厅。我不知道该坐在哪里或者类似的事情。所以我坐在了一张有几个女孩的桌子旁，我就坐在那儿。然后她走过来，说：“嗨，我的名字是布列塔尼。”我说：“嗨，我是马丽亚。”她真的了解了我。
And it was great. Every day, I would see her in the hall and we smiled very big. It was great, because I never expected to have a long term friend like that.
这太棒了。每天，我都会在走廊里见到她，我们会笑得很灿烂。这太棒了，因为我从没想过会有那样的长期朋友。
"Friend like that" meaning a white friend. Mah'Ria had never had a friend who was white before. Mah'Ria's story sounds kind of like an integration fairy tale, but it wasn't that way for everyone coming from Normandy.
“那样的朋友”是指白人朋友。马丽亚以前从未有过白人朋友。马丽亚的故事听起来有点像融合童话，但对于所有来自诺曼底的人来说并非如此。
Rihanna Curtain is a year below Mah'Ria. She also earns good grades. And she decided to research Francis Howell herself on the internet. She told her mom she wanted to go. She started seventh grade in the Francis Howell district, but in a different middle school than Mah'Ria.
蕾哈娜·库廷比马丽亚小一届。她也成绩优异。她决定自己在互联网上研究弗朗西斯·豪威尔。她告诉妈妈她想去。她开始在弗朗西斯·豪威尔学区上七年级，但在与马丽亚不同的初中。
We got tried. People tried us almost every day. After a week, you was ready to go crazy, because you're not used to nobody calling you out your name. And you don't want to do it, because then what they heard about you is true. So you've got to figure out, "OK, how can I stand up for myself without proving to them that Normandy is ghetto?" And that was the very hard part.
我们被挑战了。人们几乎每天都试图挑衅我们。一个星期后，你就准备好要疯了，因为你不习惯别人随意辱骂你的名字。你不想反击，因为那样他们听到的关于你的传言就成真的了。所以你必须想清楚，“好吧，我怎样才能为自己辩护而不向他们证明诺曼底是贫民窟？”那是非常困难的部分。
What types of things would people say or do?
人们会说什么或做什么样的事情？
My first week there, this girl, she tried me like-- how can I say this? She ain't know me and I ain't know her. And she was trying to fight me over nothing. Because she ain't like my presence, she wanted to fight and she called me a black B-I-T-C-H and a nigger who wasn't going to know nothing, who was stupid, and ghetto, and trashy. So I'm like, "I'm not going to fight you and then I get kicked out and you look like you were right."
我在那里的第一周，有个女孩，她试图挑衅我——我该怎么说呢？她不认识我，我也不认识她。她无缘无故地想跟我打架。因为她不喜欢我的存在，她想打架，还叫我黑人婊子和笨蛋，说我什么都不懂，说我愚蠢、像贫民窟的、垃圾。所以我心想，“我不会和你打架，然后被开除，这样你就显得你是对的了。”
Was that the first time you'd been called that word by a white person?
那是你第一次被白人那样称呼吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And what did that feel like?
那感觉像什么？
I felt like somebody was stabbing me in my back. It really hurt.
我感觉有人在背后捅了我一刀。这真的很受伤。
Rihanna thought about leaving and going back to Normandy. Her mom told her she could if she wanted to. She thought about it again and again, but she could not get that girl who called her names out of her head.
蕾哈娜想过离开，回到诺曼底。她妈妈告诉她，如果她想回去可以回去。她一次又一次地考虑，但她无法忘记那个叫她名字的女孩。
Because I feel like if I was to run away, if I was to come back, she was winning. And I had to prove her wrong. I had to prove to her I'm not stupid, I'm very intelligent. And just because I went to Normandy, that doesn't define who I am neither.
因为我觉得如果我要逃跑，如果我要回来，她就赢了。我必须证明她是错的。我必须向她证明我不愚蠢，我非常聪明。仅仅因为我上过诺曼底，那并不定义我是谁。
It was hard for Rihanna but she ended up having a good year. So good that one of Rihanna's teachers even asked her to help the girl who called her names with her math, something that Rihanna found ironic, given that the girl had called her stupid. So no, it wasn't always easy, but Rihanna and Mah'Ria both made it through their first year Francis Howell. It was going well, that is until the grownups came up with a new plan.
蕾哈娜过得很艰难，但她最终度过了不错的一年。甚至好到蕾哈娜的一位老师让她帮助那个骂她的女孩学习数学，蕾哈娜觉得这很有讽刺意味，因为那个女孩曾说她笨。所以不，这并不总是容易的，但蕾哈娜和马丽亚都度过了她们在弗朗西斯·豪威尔的第一年。进展很顺利，直到成年人想出了一个新计划。
Nikole Hannah Jones. Coming up, Adults to the Not Rescue. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
尼科尔·汉娜·琼斯。接下来，成年人并没有来救援。芝加哥公共广播电台的节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Our program today, The Problem We All Live With. If you're just tuning in, we're telling the story of the Normandy School District that Michael Brown graduated from. In the 2013 to 2014 school year, Mah'Ria, who we heard in the first half of the show, finished eighth grade at the mostly white Francis Howell School District.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目，《我们共同居住的问题》。如果你刚加入，我们正在讲述迈克尔·布朗毕业的诺曼底学区的故事。在2013到2014学年，我们在前半部分节目中听到的马丽亚，在大部分是白人的弗朗西斯·豪威尔学区完成了八年级。
Meanwhile, the same year, the mostly black Normandy District that had lost its accreditation, was still operating, though barely. The way the transfer law works, the failing district has to pay to educate its students, even if they leave. So Normandy was paying for 1,000 students to be educated in accredited districts elsewhere, like Francis Howell. It also had to pay for transportation for the students. Altogether, it was $10.4 million that year. Everybody expected that losing a quarter of the students in the Normandy District would be bad. Nobody knew just how bad it was going to turn out. Again, here's Nikole Hannah Jones.
同时，同一年，失去了认证的、大部分是黑人的诺曼底学区仍在运行，尽管很艰难。转学法的运作方式是，失败的学区必须支付教育其学生的费用，即使他们离开了。所以诺曼底当时正在支付1000名学生在别处（如弗朗西斯·豪威尔）接受有认证的教育的费用。它还必须支付学生的交通费。总共那一年是1040万美元。每个人都预计失去诺曼底学区四分之一的学生会很糟糕。没人知道结果会变得有多糟糕。再说一遍，这是尼科尔·汉娜·琼斯。
It didn't take long before the transfer law was bankrupting Normandy. By the fall of 2013, the impoverished Normandy District was sending more than a $1 million  a month to whiter, wealthier ones. Back at the height of the St. Louis desegregation program in the 1980s, they had a term for this-- black gold.
没过多久，转学法就让诺曼底破产了。到2013年秋天，贫困的诺曼底学区每个月要向更白、更富裕的学区输送超过100万美元。早在20世纪80年代圣路易斯废除种族隔离计划的高峰期，他们对此有一个术语——“黑金”。
While wealthier districts were getting an influx of cash, Normandy was careening towards financial insolvency. It shut down a school. The district had to cut staff. That's when the state made a desperation move.
当较富裕的学区获得大量资金注入时，诺曼底正冲向财务无力偿债。它关闭了一所学校。该学区不得不裁减人员。就在那时，州政府采取了绝望的行动。
As the day ends, so does the Normandy School District, or at least--
随着这一天结束，诺曼底学区也随之结束，或者至少——
The state was taking over the Normandy District. At first, nobody knew what that meant. Douglas Carr, the Normandy teacher, says they received no explanation.
州政府正在接管诺曼底学区。起初，没人知道那意味着什么。道格拉斯·卡尔，那位诺曼底老师，说他们没有得到解释。
Rumors start flying around, they were going to dissolve the district and that students were going to be sent all over, other places.
谣言四起，说他们要解散学区，学生将被送到各处，其他地方。
If Normandy folded, all of its students, an additional 3,000 of them, would have to be absorbed into other school districts. Bankruptcy, it turns out, will be the ultimate integration plan. So instead, the state took over. And its first big move was to give the district a new name.
如果诺曼底倒闭，它所有的学生，另外3000名学生，将不得不被吸收到其他学区。结果证明，破产将是最终的融合计划。所以，州政府接管了。它的第一个大举措是给学区起个新名字。
It was Normandy School District, and now it is Normandy Schools Collaborative.
过去是诺曼底学区，现在它是诺曼底学校合作社。
The Normandy Schools Collaborative. But this was more than just rebranding. According to the state, a shiny new name also came with a shiny new accreditation status.
诺曼底学校合作社。但这不仅仅是品牌重塑。根据州政府的说法，一个闪亮的新名字也带来了闪亮的新认证状态。
We weren't an unaccredited district. We were non-accredited.
我们不是一个未获认证的学区。我们是无认证学区。
The difference between unaccredited and non-accredited, those three letters, changed everything.
“未获认证”和“无认证”之间的区别，那几个字母，改变了一切。
We were the only non-accredited district in the world.
我们是世界上唯一的无认证学区。
So the state says, "We've taken you over. We've given you a new name. And now you have a new accreditation status that has never existed in history of the state."
所以州政府说，“我们接管了你们。我们给了你们一个新名字。现在你们有了一个州历史上从未存在过的认证状态。”
And because we're non-accredited, the transfer law no longer applies. OK? Students who transferred now do not necessarily have the right to stay in that situation. They have to come back.
而且因为我们是无认证的，转学法不再适用。好吗？那些已经转学的学生现在不一定有权利保持那种状况。他们必须回来。
It's confusing, I know. So let me repeat-- the Normandy School District was unaccredited. But the new Normandy Collaborative District was non-accredited. Now that the district was no longer unaccredited, according to the state, the 1,000 students who had escaped now had to come back.
这很令人困惑，我知道。所以我再说一遍——诺曼底学区是“未获认证”的。但新的诺曼底合作学区是“无认证”的。现在学区不再是“未获认证”的了，根据州政府的说法，那1000名逃离的学生现在必须回来。
On July 29, I found out, via mail--
7月29日，我通过邮件发现了——
Nedra Martin remembers getting the letter when Mah'Ria was at a camp for the Francis Howell volleyball team.
内德拉·马丁记得在马丽亚参加弗朗西斯·豪威尔排球队夏令营时收到了那封信。
Francis Howell is no longer accepting any students from the Normandy because Normandy is now called the Collaborative something.
弗朗西斯·豪威尔不再接受任何来自诺曼底的学生，因为诺曼底现在叫合作社什么的。
Normandy Schools Collaborative.
诺曼底学校合作社。
That's it. That's it. You know, I'm talking to myself, "Surely, this is a mistake. Not my daughter. That's a mistake."
就是这样。就是这样。你知道，我对自己说，“肯定是个错误。不是我女儿。那是个错误。”
Yeah, I had come from camp, I think it was three days. I got my t-shirt and everything. I still have it to this day-- Francis Howell Volleyball Camp. And she was like, "Mah'Ria, I gotta tell you something." And I could see in her face that it was not good. So she told me, and I'm like, "Oh, my Jesus. What?" "You can't go back to Francis Howell. You've got to go back to Normandy." "Uh, excuse me. Come again? What did you just say?"
是的，我从夏令营回来，我想是三天。我拿到了我的T恤和所有东西。直到今天我还有它——弗朗西斯·豪威尔排球训练营。她跟我说，“马丽亚，我得告诉你一件事。”从她的脸上我看出不是好消息。所以她告诉我了，我说：“噢，我的天啊。什么？”“你不能回弗朗西斯·豪威尔了。你得回诺曼底。”“啊，不好意思。再说一遍？你刚才说什么？”
So Nedra found herself back in her car on lunch breaks, making calls. She called Francis Howell administrators and teachers and extolled the virtues of her daughter. She told them Mah'Ria was an honor student at Francis Howell and that she stood out on the volleyball team. Nedra found herself pleading for an exception. But Francis Howell was firm. It was not going to be taking any Normandy Collaborative transfers.
所以内德拉发现自己又坐在午休时的车里打电话。她给弗朗西斯·豪威尔的管理人员和老师打电话，赞扬她女儿的优点。她告诉他们马丽亚是弗朗西斯·豪威尔的荣誉学生，而且她在排球队表现突出。内德拉发现自己在恳求例外。但弗朗西斯·豪威尔很坚定。它不打算接收任何诺曼底合作社的转校生。
I literally, mentally, had a vision of a herd of cattle being pushed on a truck, being herded back to where they came from.
我真的，在脑海里，有一个成群的牛被推上卡车，被赶回它们来时的方向的幻象。
Mah'Ria had spent a year making new friends, joining sports teams, settling in. Now she'd be leaving. Think about how this would feel if you were 14, about to enter ninth grade. Mah'Ria shut down. She didn't tell any of her friends at Francis Howell she wasn't coming back, not even Brittany. She just disappeared.
马丽亚花了一年时间交新朋友，参加运动队，安定下来。现在她要离开了。想想看，如果你14岁，即将进入九年级，会有什么感觉。马丽亚封闭了自己。她没有告诉弗朗西斯·豪威尔的任何朋友她不会回来了，甚至没告诉布列塔尼。她就这样消失了。
When the state took over, it fired all the teachers over the summer. And then, scrambling, it rehired some of the same ones before the school year started. Morale was incredibly low. This was last August, almost a year ago. Michael Brown was killed August 9, nine days before school started. Michael Brown was buried in the cemetery alongside Normandy High School's football field. He'd just graduated three weeks before.
当州政府接管时，它在夏天解雇了所有的老师。然后，在匆忙中，它在学年开始前重新雇佣了一些人。士气非常低落。那是去年八月，差不多一年前。迈克尔·布朗在8月9日被杀，距离开学还有九天。迈克尔·布朗被埋葬在诺曼底高中橄榄球场旁边的墓地里。他三周前刚毕业。
Mah'Ria started her freshman year at Normandy High School. In the meantime, a group of parents, including Nedra, had filed a lawsuit against the state and were crossing their fingers that a judge would intervene. And eventually, a judge sided with the parents. He wrote in his ruling, "Every day a student attends an unaccredited school, the child could suffer harm that cannot be repaired." He said that Normandy students should be allowed to leave.
马丽亚在诺曼底高中开始了她的一年级。同时，包括内德拉在内的一群家长对州政府提起了诉讼，并祈祷法官能介入。最终，一位法官站在了家长一边。他在裁决中写道，“学生每天上未获认证的学校，孩子都可能受到无法弥补的伤害。”他说诺曼底学生应该被允许离开。
But even after that, Francis Howell forced every Normandy student who wanted to return to get his or her own personal injunction from the judge. Again, Francis Howell did not respond to requests to talk to us. For nearly three months, Mah'Ria tried to make it work at Normandy High School. But finally, she gave up and transferred back to Francis Howell. Last month, she completed her freshman year. She's continued to do well.
但即便在那之后，弗朗西斯·豪威尔强迫每一个想返回的诺曼底学生从法官那里获得他或她自己的个人禁令。再说一遍，弗朗西斯·豪威尔没有回应我们的采访请求。近三个月来，马丽亚试图在诺曼底高中适应，但最终她放弃了，转回了弗朗西斯·豪威尔。上个月，她完成了高一学业。她继续表现良好。
Right now, I want this school to be the school that I stay at for my sophomore, junior, and senior year. I don't want to keep flip-flopping between schools, so I'm hopeful that I'll stay. I'm just really settling, enjoying my time at Francis Howell, just in case that ends.
现在，我希望这所学校是我高二、高三和高四会一直待下去的地方。我不想在学校之间反复折腾，所以我希望我会留下来。我真的很安定，享受在弗朗西斯·豪威尔的时光，以防它结束。
A lot of Normandy kids opted to stay put, even Rihanna, the girl who was called a racial slur in the lunchroom and was determined to stay at Francis Howell. The back and forth just wore her down. She decided to stay. She's paid a cost for staying.
很多诺曼底的孩子选择了留下来，甚至是蕾哈娜，那个在食堂里被用种族歧视用语辱骂、决心留在弗朗西斯·豪威尔的女孩。反复的折腾让她疲惫不堪。她决定留下来。她为留下来付出了代价。
Here is what the last few months at Normandy Middle School have been like. The principal at Rihanna's middle school, not even a year into the job, resigned. And at Rihanna's graduation, the vice president of the Missouri State Board of Education spoke. He apologized to the graduates, he said the state owed students, quote, "A collective apology for failing to provide you with the education experience you should have." In all of my years of reporting, I don't think I've ever heard a state official apologize to students for failing to educate them.
这就是诺曼底中学过去几个月的情况。蕾哈娜所在的初中校长，上任不到一年就辞职了。而在蕾哈娜的毕业典礼上，密苏里州教育委员会副主席发表了讲话。他向毕业生道歉，他说州政府欠学生们一个“集体道歉，因为未能为你们提供你们本应获得的教育体验。”在我多年的报道中，我不认为我曾经听过州官员向未能教育他们的学生道歉。
The guy who now has the job of transforming the Normandy schools is Charles Pearson. He's the third superintendent in three years. When we meet in Normandy, Charles Pearson is dapper, in a gray pinstripe suit and bowtie. He has a long track record in education, but until he was asked to lead Normandy he had never spent a day as the head of the school district. Still, he sounds like any other superintendent of a struggling district. He's a cheerleader and upbeat about the potential for a turnaround.
现在负责改变诺曼底学校的人是查尔斯·皮尔逊。他是三年里的第三位校长。当我们在诺曼底见面时，查尔斯·皮尔逊穿着得体，穿着灰色条纹西装和蝴蝶结。他在教育界有很长的记录，但在被要求领导诺曼底之前，他从未有一天担任过学区负责人。尽管如此，他听起来就像任何一个处于困境学区的校长。他是一位拉拉队长，对转机的潜力感到乐观。
CHARLES PEARSON: We need to really create a new Normandy.
查尔斯·皮尔逊：我们确实需要创造一个新的诺曼底。
Tell me what does turning around Normandy look like.
告诉我扭转诺曼底看起来是什么样的。
CHARLES PEARSON: I think, well, the first indicators of a turnaround is if within three years, at the end of our third year, all of our schools will be accredited again. We're doing the things that improve instruction. We are.
查尔斯·皮尔逊：我认为，嗯，扭转的第一个指标是如果三年内，在我们第三年结束时，我们所有的学校都将再次获得认证。我们正在做那些改善教学的事情。我们确实在做。
When I hear this, and I've written about these types of schools for a long time--
当我听到这个，而且我报道这类学校已经很长时间了——
CHARLES PEARSON: Sure, of course.
查尔斯·皮尔逊：当然，当然。
What you're saying is, small, incremental progress. But meanwhile, there's kids in those classrooms.
你所说的是小而渐进的进步。但同时，教室里有孩子。
CHARLES PEARSON: Mm-hmm.
查尔斯·皮尔逊：嗯。
There are kids who are going through these schools and not getting the education that they deserve while everyone's trying to fix it. It's not like those kids are removed somewhere and getting a good education while you guys figure it out.
有孩子正在经历这些学校，却没有得到他们应得的教育，而每个人都在试图修复它。并不是说那些孩子被转移到别的地方去了，而在你们想出办法时正在接受良好的教育。
CHARLES PEARSON: Right.
查尔斯·皮尔逊：对。
There's kids. There's kids who, for the last three years, have been going through utter chaos. And when they graduate, they're absolutely going to be behind. And I just wonder why is this OK?
有孩子。有孩子在过去三年里一直在经历彻底的混乱。而当他们毕业时，他们绝对会落后。我只是想知道为什么这没关系？
CHARLES PEARSON: No one has ever argued it's OK. No, that's not the argument, that it's OK.
查尔斯·皮尔逊：从来没有人争论过这没关系。不，那不是争论，说没关系。
But by virtue of what is happening--
但因为正在发生的事情——
CHARLES PEARSON: Yeah, but I'm not saying-- I think it's the reality of where they are, and it's the reality that they're struggling. But if we were OK, we wouldn't be fixing it. It's not OK. There are lives. You asked me a minute ago why would I be doing this? It's 4,000 black kids. It's 4,000.
查尔斯·皮尔逊：是的，但我并不是说——我认为这是他们所处环境的现实，也是他们正在挣扎的现实。但如果我们真的没问题，我们就不需要修复它了。这没关系。这是生命。你刚才问我为什么要这样做？这是4000名黑人孩子。是4000名。
Why would I say yes? Why would we keep pushing forward when the legislature may make us close? It's 4,000 black kids. So for whatever time we have, they will get a quality education. They will get that. Because we know exactly what to do.
为什么我会说是？为什么我们要继续前进，当立法机构可能强迫我们关闭时？这是4000名黑人孩子。所以无论我们有多少时间，他们都会获得优质教育。他们会得到的。因为我们确切地知道该怎么做。
Can I just say, with all due respect, I've had this conversation with superintendents and principals in districts that look just like Normandy and schools that look just like Normandy for more than a decade. And you can look at districts and schools with the same racial makeup in every urban community across the country. And the same thing is said, "We know we need to do." But the schools do not turn around. Typically, an entire district does not turn around.
我能说，恕我直言，在超过十年的时间里，我和看起来像诺曼底的学区和学校里的校长和老师们进行过这种对话。你可以在全国每一个城市社区看到拥有相同种族构成的学区和学校。人们说的是同样的事情，“我们知道我们需要做什么。”但学校并没有扭转。通常，整个学区并没有扭转。
CHARLES PEARSON: Yes, an entire district has never turned around. It has never happened. But that doesn't relieve us of the charge to attempt to do it. So you're right, it hasn't been done. However, our obligation to attempt to do it, it still remains. The kids are here. So you're right. It hasn't been done. But it's our watch.
查尔斯·皮尔逊：是的，整个学区从未扭转过。从来没有发生过。但这并不能免除我们尝试去做的责任。所以你是对的，它还没做到。然而，我们尝试去做它的义务，它依然存在。孩子们在这里。所以你是对的。它还没做到。但现在是我们的职责。
So then knowing that, knowing that in these high poverty segregated districts the students aren't doing well, is it possible for a black child in Missouri to get an equal education?
那么知道这一点，知道在这些高贫困隔离学区里学生表现不好，密苏里州的黑人孩子有可能获得平等的教育吗？
CHARLES PEARSON: Wow, what a great question. The answer right now, I really don't know.
查尔斯·皮尔逊：哇，多好的问题。现在的答案，我真的不知道。
Here's what the evidence shows. A few weeks after I met with Charles Pearson, a reporter from the St. Louis Post-Dispatch named Elisa Crouch spent the day following a Normandy senior to all of his classes. She chose Cameron Hensley, a driven honor student. She met him at Normandy High School in time to head to his first period.
这是证据显示的。在我见到查尔斯·皮尔逊几周后，圣路易斯邮报的一位名叫埃莉萨·克劳奇的记者花了一天时间跟随一名诺曼底高三学生去上他所有的课。她选择了卡梅伦·亨斯利，一个有上进心的荣誉学生。她准时在诺曼底高中见到了他，准备去上他的第一节课。
We went into AP English, and it's held in a science lab. The classroom across the hall, where it should be held, smells like mildew and the ventilation system doesn't work. I looked around. Stools were up on tables. There was one other student, his friend, Arianna, and Mr. Drummer, the AP English teacher who is not certified to teach AP English, who at that moment was not in the classroom and who would just come and go.
我们进入了AP英语课，它在科学实验室里举行。大厅对面的教室本应该是它举办的地方，闻起来有霉味，通风系统也坏了。我环顾四周。凳子放在桌子上。还有另外一个学生，他的朋友阿里安娜，以及德拉默先生，那位没有获得AP英语教学认证的AP英语老师，他当时不在教室，只是来来去去。
She says at some point Mr. Drummer gave the two students a worksheet. This was advanced placement. That's the highest English class the school offered. But Elisa said the worksheet looked to be at the middle school level. Cameron and other students finished in five minutes. They had 40 minutes left.
她说在某个时刻，德拉默先生给了这两个学生一张练习表。这是先修课程。那是学校提供的最高级英语课。但埃莉萨说练习表看起来像是初中水平的。卡梅伦和其他学生五分钟就完成了。他们还剩下40分钟。
Second period was jazz band. We went down to the jazz room, the jazz band room, and the instructor was not there. There was no substitute teacher. So Cameron said he normally goes to the counselor's office because this was not unusual. And we spent that whole entire hour talking about what his ambitions are, his history in the Normandy school system, and how he regretted not leaving.
第二节课是爵士乐队。我们去了爵士房间，爵士乐队房间，教练不在。没有代课老师。所以卡梅伦说他通常会去辅导员办公室，因为这并不罕见。我们花了一整个小时谈论他的志向，他在诺曼底学校系统的历史，以及他如何后悔没有离开。
Third period physics class teacher, who is a permanent sub, hasn't taught since January, hasn't planned a lesson since then. Fourth period was precalculus taught by a retired teacher who does care and was teaching something. I went to lunch with Cameron. Then was choir, and then he had two periods of band. And so that was pretty much the rest of the day.
第三节课物理课老师，是一位常驻代课老师，从一月起就没教过书，从那以后就没规划过一节课。第四节课是退休老师教的预科微积分，他确实关心，也在教些东西。我和卡梅伦一起去吃了午饭。然后是合唱，然后他有两节乐队课。所以那差不多就是剩下的一天。
So four periods of music, three academic classes, one where a teacher actually taught. It's hard to imagine a bar lower than that. And Cameron's an honor student. For his part, Pearson, the superintendent, said he was shocked to read in the paper what was happening, or more accurately, what was not happening at the high school.
所以四节音乐课，三节学术课，只有一节有老师真正教学。很难想象比这更低的门槛了。卡梅伦是个荣誉学生。对于皮尔逊，那位校长，他说他很震惊在报纸上读到正在发生的事情，或者更确切地说，高中里没有发生什么事情。
While Normandy is falling apart, over at Francis Howell, none of the things that parents were worried about came true. No one got stabbed. Test scores did not drop-- at all. And at least so far, the influx of black students hasn't caused white parents to flee. Mah'Ria's thriving. Where the transfer law forced integration, it's working.
当诺曼底分崩离析时，在弗朗西斯·豪威尔，家长们担心的任何事情都没有发生。没人被刺伤。考试成绩也没有下降——根本没有。而且至少目前为止，黑人学生的涌入并没有导致白人家长逃离。马丽亚正在茁壮成长。在转学法强制融合的地方，它正在起作用。
The educational devastation in Normandy has finally gotten the attention of the state's most powerful people, including state legislators and the governor. The law says they can't keep the Normandy kids in schools that aren't accredited. So they're proposing charter schools and virtual school programs that students would attend. They're sending in teacher coaches from wealthier districts. The idea is, try anything they can to keep Normandy students inside the district. This is how far they will go to avoid that one thing, that one thing that already seems to be working-- integration.
诺曼底的教育破坏终于引起了该州最有权势的人的注意，包括州议员和州长。法律规定他们不能把诺曼底的孩子留在没有获得认证的学校里。所以他们正在提议学生将要参加的特许学校和虚拟学校项目。他们正在派遣来自更富裕学区的教师教练。他们的想法是，尝试他们能做的任何事情来把诺曼底学生留在学区内。这就是他们为了避免那件事会走多远，那件事——似乎已经在起作用的事情——融合。
Nikole Hannah Jones, she's a staff writer at The New York Times Magazine. She also did a great story about the Normandy schools for Pro Publica. You can read that at their website, propublica.org. And she's written this amazing article-- I cannot recommend this highly enough-- about choosing a school for her own kid in New York City's segregated school system. That's at The New York Times website.
尼科尔·汉娜·琼斯，她是《纽约时报杂志》的一名专职撰稿人。她还为Pro Publica做了一个关于诺曼底学校的精彩报道。你可以在他们的网站propublica.org上阅读。她写了这篇令人惊叹的文章——我怎么推荐都不为过——关于为她自己的孩子在纽约市种族隔离的学校系统中选择一所学校。那在《纽约时报》网站上。
[MUSIC - SYL JOHNSON, "IS IT BECAUSE I'M BLACK?"]
[音乐 - 西尔·约翰逊，“是因为我是黑人吗？”]
Our program was produced today by Chana Joffe-Walt and Jonathan Menjivar with Zoe Chase, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Miki Meek, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike, editing help from Joel Lovell. Julie Snyder was the consulting editor for this episode.
我们的节目今天由查纳·乔夫-沃尔特和乔纳森·门吉瓦尔制作，佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·福、米基·米克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与，乔尔·洛弗尔提供编辑帮助。朱莉·斯奈德是这一集的咨询编辑。
Other editing help for this episode from Neil Drumming. Production help from Emmanuel Dzotsi. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Our staff includes Elise Bergerson, Emily Condon, Kimberly Henderson, and Seth Lind. Research help today from Michelle Harris. Music help from Damian Graf from Rob Geddis.
本集其他编辑帮助来自尼尔·德拉明。制作帮助来自伊曼纽尔·佐齐。我们的技术导演是马特·蒂尔尼。我们的工作人员包括伊莉斯·伯格森、艾米丽·康登、金伯利·亨德森和塞思·林德。今天的研究帮助来自米歇尔·哈里斯。来自罗布·格迪斯的达米安·格拉夫提供音乐帮助。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he finally explained to me why he showed up at work wearing hiking boots and a suit covered in dirt.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心PRX提供给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他最终向我解释了为什么他穿着登山靴和一身沾满泥土的西装来上班。
I had come from camp, got my t-shirt and everything. I still have it to this day.
我从夏令营回来，拿到了我的T恤和所有东西。直到今天我还有它。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带给你们更多《美国生活》的故事。